you
oh [ __ ] Friday afternoon unlike smoking
out of a [ __ ] clean pipe just to get
the weekend started I'm smoking this
blue cookies I want to pick up some
[ __ ] Godzilla I got some monster
biscuits it's all dried in the car and
90 degree weather honey where you going
it's a beautiful day to be alive here in
Southern California the birds are
chirping the sun's out not a [ __ ]
cloud in the sky I'm not driving around
in [ __ ] traffic I'm here my yard
minding my own [ __ ] business about to
get stoned to the [ __ ] gills I
suggest you do the same I wanna go
outside and mingle and talk to be my
it's happy hour get the [ __ ] out of here
with your [ __ ] hat I'm gonna stick
this [ __ ] flip-flop up your [ __ ]
ass but anyway we're here we're queer
[Music]
smokin California's finest I took
everything I had to do I want to digital
with the mobility class I [ __ ] met
with the dude I having an audition
I had a conference call it don't [ __ ] it
in front foot you're gonna show them
that The Improv you [ __ ] coming are
you gonna sit there at home I'm broken
get come on [ __ ] down his reefer
they're stars as edibles Lee's gonna be
down there or [ __ ] up and you're gonna
be home like a [ __ ] do some BOTS for
what saving my money for you I've seen
gives a [ __ ] you know I'm saying get
your [ __ ] together get out of the
[ __ ] house plot that mug somebody
smack somebody do something but it's
better than sitting there well last year
at this time Overeem who gives a [ __ ]
we're getting down tonight's Friday
night his dick suck at night you want to
sit there [ __ ] talking to your
[ __ ] stupid friends
look at that
blowing [ __ ] clouds if I called you
right now the smoke would come out of
the [ __ ] phone when you answered it
that's how we do it cuts up his I show
tomorrow night the Melrose improv then
we're off next [ __ ] Thursday to
Austin Texas baby yeehaw barbeque [ __ ]
Chuy's Papa those I'm goin [ __ ] down
I'm gonna jujitsu it on it it's over I'm
gettin down at listen I love [ __ ]
Texas I know about you [ __ ] in
my world is [ __ ] NYC and [ __ ] Texas
h-town Dallas Austin always something
crack-a-lackin' nicest [ __ ] beep in
the world
nicest people in the world I'm gonna see
my [ __ ] goombazz crystal and Bobby and
[ __ ] kooky spooky and my man Dave
Wilde is coming down from Dallas for
Cuban [ __ ] pastries listen and don't
end we know how to [ __ ] party down so
if your name Whitney [ __ ] Austin next
week get your [ __ ] down man we're
going deep into the murky waters even
George Bush's [ __ ] coming that's when
you know it's a [ __ ] party he's
bringing some of that blow from the
[ __ ] Escobar days wait dick should we
smoke another smoke another what the
[ __ ] good always [ __ ] weak men stoned
sort of [ __ ] Jesus nice drink I don't
wanna do nothing all I wanna do is smoke
this [ __ ] reefer I don't give a [ __ ]
if I got no friends I'll just smoke this
reefer and talk to myself even talk to
yourself
not a bad conversation every wants to
light your little bad breath from
yourself but besides that it's a
beautiful [ __ ] left
oh I love it
tonight we got one show I'll be home by
[ __ ] 11 o'clock tomorrow one show 8
p.m. at the Melrose improv I'll be home
by 11 o'clock you know me guys I keep it
[ __ ] simple I don't bother nobody
we got Homer from time to time like
doctor beliefs in it Zanna
[ __ ] my diaphragm is stoned you
understand had to give them a [ __ ]
pretzel last night
we're men [ __ ] sweat from the THC
tremendous this is what I'm talking
about people I don't want to bother
nobody just when I get high with you and
leave you the [ __ ] alone I got no
answers I don't know nobody I don't know
nobody all I know is reefer and a show
at 8:00 p.m. tonight all right
besides that I love you [ __ ]
with all my heart without you guys
wouldn't I wouldn't even have a [ __ ]
week okay we got the podcast we got the
videos we [ __ ] around we got a nice
thing going on without you guys I
wouldn't be able to shoot a [ __ ]
special so I want to thank you I want
you to have a good [ __ ] weekend you
know don't get arrested and kiss your
[ __ ] mother and that's it that's the
best advice I can give you gotta kiss
your mother call from time to time mom I
[ __ ] love you god sucker
they love their [ __ ] mom's dropping off
for 24 bingo yeah whatever the [ __ ] it
always helps that Joey why you chitchat
when you spark who all shows up before
[ __ ] balls of the best weed and said
nobody so don't give me none of your
[ __ ] lip okay I got problems myself I
got a fungi I won't go away
but I tell you [ __ ] I'm stoned
I gotta go inside not an organized
material and that's it if I want this
special to be good I gotta be [ __ ]
faccia whether with this [ __ ] thing
so if I talk about it what he under -
all I got so sometimes you just got one
- a little movies
I don't know TV shows I've had nothing
but then I got I don't want to know that
[ __ ] I just want to do the [ __ ]
podcast smoke dope and torture you
[ __ ] here on periscope have a
good night I love you [ __ ]
that's the idea prob tonight eight
o'clock